Okay,
I think that's true.
Uh,
I think,
um,
the supreme court has a lot of
independent authority would just take
this term,
you know,
it may be that the city council of
Chicago,
of New York of La wants to ban handguns
in their city.
Well,
as of this year,
too bad supreme court says you can't do
it.
You know that that is real power.
In one,
one of my favorite quotes about the
supreme court comes from Robert Jackson
who said,
we are not justice Robert Jackson who
said we are not final because we are
infallible.
We are infallible because we are final.
Somebody has to have the last word and
in our country it's the supreme court.
I don't think I have a judicial
philosophy to speak of.
I,
I think I,
I guess in my book,
in my analysis,
I am somewhat cynical,
realistic,
whatever you want to call it,
about the political nature of judging
when it comes to the constitution.
When you are addressing questions like,
does the constitution protect a woman's
right to choose abortion?
Does the constitution allow a,
a university to consider race in
admissions?
I don't think those questions have right
or wrong answers when it comes to
interpreting the constitution.
I think there are reasonable views on
both sides as a legal matter.
What I think is that there are
political,
the,
that,
it depends what you think in terms of
your political philosophy.
I think political philosophy means more
than legal competence or expertise in
deciding to big constitutional issues.
Yeah,
mine.
Well,
I mean,
I,
I think there are.
I think there are terrific thinkers
about the court.
I like reading Cass Sunstein.
I like reading Larry tribe.
I like reading a Richard Posner.
I liked reading a Ronald Dworkin.
Um,
but you know,
this is not a moment where there are a
lot of judges out there who are legal
philosophers in the way that there have
been in the past.
There are people with distinctive
philosophies that they apply in
interesting and important ways,
but I don't think there are a lot of
geniuses in the way that there were.
There were when there was homes and
learn at hand.